we are half an hour by car from asunción
the capital of Paraguay
this town San Lorenzo is home to 270,000
people many live on the verge of poverty
this snack bar belongs to Mata Meza she
started the business a few years ago by
taking out a microloan empanadas other
snacks drinks hamburgers in the evenings
I'm here 24 hours a day it's my house
and my business in one business isn't
bad for Mata Mesa
no she won't get rich either she's
visited regularly by Nancy Ramos who
helps her improve her life step by step
Ramos works for fundación Paraguay the
organization that also mediated the loan
when it almost comes to visit she brings
along a tablet computer and a
questionnaire she calls the poverty
stoplight when I ask a family if they're
poor they often don't know how to answer
they can't put their poverty into words
with our stoplight system we can find
out step by step how the poverty
manifests itself the key is that Mata
Meza assesses her situation herself from
her finances to her health the questions
Ramos asks are very specific for example
here we have the savings indicator this
picture means the family has no savings
this one means they're able to save
sometimes and this family saves for up
to six months the goal is to get from
red to yellow to green at each visit the
colors identify areas of progress and
deficits one red line for Mata Meza is
the bathroom
Dora look at her look am i right now
what I most need is a new bathroom I
want all of this to become more modern
the floor everything better for my
family and my son yes Table four army
familia por amigo
that's the goal for the coming weeks one
more photo for the file
Marta and her problem are identified
when the Ramos returns some progress
should have been made almost a quarter
of all paraguayans live in poverty but a
few years ago there were a lot more
efforts to create new sources of income
have been producing results this is
where the fundación para gua takes its
cue and it's focusing its work on women
we very much support diversification
multiple income sources for example
through micro franchises women have a
way to earn money quickly and directly
yeah oh ha ha
Harris this is where Josefa Jimenez
lives she's been taking part in the
program for three months and is
specializing in soap with the help of
fundacion paraguay a-- it's becoming a
humming business by this up here from
Fundacion paraguay a--
then i mix it and sell it it works very
well
Nancy Ramos comes here to to talk with
cassava about her situation and Rosa is
working towards a very specific goal I'd
like to have a new kitchen that's my
dream and I want to achieve it for now
Josefa still cooks outdoors but soon
that's going to change